hi I'm Greg good idea we don't watch the
honest trailer for that send again this
is a heads up I might not be able to
upload for a couple days I gave a
warning in a couple other videos I am
moving right now we're gonna tear this
set down right when we're done filming
this video yeah maybe the light yeah
that I'm again scare Christ's love that
skip price is the best one is over
Clooney right yeah we've got nipples as
a funny one trend fatness free beneath
after Joe Shinhwa debates bad name silly
nobody could cave without it but before
sex night they did a joke like that
there's no made a movie they've got the
Dark Knight just ride master is using
one of the best yet oddly not that
successful Batman filled is so good it
allowed Christopher Nolan to do whatever
he wanted afterwards except distance
himself from the franchise
it is perfectly told superhero origin
story back when we weren't sick of
superhero origin story
realistically explained hella boy became
a crime-fighting bad ninja instead of a
trust-fund kid with a deep-seated fear
of wells I mean had to be even odd had
become well man right experience a
feature-length attempt to ground Batman
in reality where the Batmobile was just
a bridge-building rocket car Wayne tech
had laying around the Batcave was simply
part of New York's Underground Railroad
you'll right
was involved in the Underground Railroad
and Apache that someone had gone cloud
of angry bats are some BS but who cares
how cool is this follow along on every
step of Bruce Wayne's heroic journey
from cosplaying as a hobo to stealing
food to blowing up a school and witness
his brutal training at the hands of the
Liam of nieces mr. plan to stop crimes
by using a microwave gun to vaporize
their special gear juice to kick off the
perch
wait what I thought this was supposed to
be the realistic one that sounds like
something Adam West would go up again
but the show was on the only criminals
plaguing Gotham
there's also Batman who if you think
about it is the violent when Lulu
answers to no one waging a one-man war
in the law itself
[Music]
everything's ready
property sorry
steel canisters murder if you make a
train dude joining this longer on its
one-man quest for justice are a lot of
other people like Alfred a butler so
loyal he'll drag Batman sedated
girlfriend into the back of a car no
questions asked this is marshal Lucius
Fox a man who might be helping Bruce to
be a better serial killer for all he
knows someone from exactly what you're
doing when I'm asked
I don't have the line Jim Gordon a cop
with the morals glasses and mustache of
Ned Flanders Rachel Dawes my childhood
friend with a mysterious past of drinkin
condensed milk
Alfred soak into the conventional from
the top shelf and Shirley is that King
Joffrey that is it huh leave out the
boards to wait I don't know that that
takes Batman from ponds and irrelevant
[Music]
with the right mix of gritty realism and
comic-book theatricality that the
perfectly focused character driven story
except for the whole third act and get
that machine into a station that will
cause a chain reaction that'll make runs
entire cities work and the fact that has
the dialogue is cutesy repetition the
things someone said earlier to visit NZ
in teaching is that my company's future
why I can be fun that doesn't wander
from attorney did you get member shut up
no wonder this would be so good I only
had to write have a script storage
Gerald Lee got from Abby's laws actually
ringing ah ha ha ha ha ha yes I own my
plate this way now I'm going to not be
wasted in this movie but he is and what
does the Fox say a ring of English
orangutans dick help who's Wayne got his
groove back the League of Shadows has
been a chair could use huge corruption
we attacked him love to trade shifts
with plague rats but London to the
ground and so Firefly may crash won Best
Picture discovered Justin Bieber later
on be Amin the Dark Knight worse than
Joel Schumacher did another water
running strategist and a master of
theatricality but I found your one
hidden weakness getting this mission
overview
the screen junkies Roast of Batman watch
now no police Corps sure if you'd like
to watch the roast of Batman click the
box to the left to see the Caped
Crusader's greatest foes you know that's
not watching out a lot laughs pretty
funny this is pretty funny yeah it is
it's pretty funny pretty funny it's
pretty fun it's like real ass comedian
it's it's meaning the screen jockey
scheme and stuff oh cool yeah how run
nikolassarah little Joker
I did not realize King Joffrey was that
boy yeah I found it a couple years ago
blew my mind I was like he's so adorable
compared to the anvil human being
clearly just got range man yeah just got
range need a sad creepy boy or really
maniacal crazy
they've also bring up a great point
about the one man's quest who has the
help of a lot of it yeah they realize
that it still they pointed it out that's
probably maybe it's believable and seem
like this is plausible because he does
have the aid of Alfred Lucius Fox Rachel
well that's something I always really
appreciated about Batman Begins
especially is like you really do get the
sense that while Bruce Wayne is an
extraordinary guy he does need a few key
PPM like he does have to trust someone
yeah if you look at that poster for bet
or any of the films of the Dark Knight
trilogy they always have a large list of
cast members not all of them are like
superheroes yeah exactly a lot of
important people behind the cape and
exactly Batman does kill a few people in
this that one part I don't think that I
can't remember if there's a shop of one
when there's that moment when Gordon's
like I pulled my car and he's like a run
line and then they pull and he like runs
over a cop car I showed in it in a
little bit of trailer he runs over a cop
car I don't think they show like the
people going yeah murder these few cops
unless they weren't it was their cost in
the cop car they pick cops just pulled
up oh [ __ ]
I'm pretty sure that's how it played out
it's been a couple years of the past
I think Madden begins up pretty sure for
that yeah I feel like even in the best
of Batman movies
always something problematic about the
way he deals with trying Elsa the other
fifty point like how you destroying
property of a major property damage yeah
and especially the more height in the
world or in a more realistic world sorry
we're like you have to think about the
mechanics of this more realistically
you're like yeah he isn't taking a lot
from Gotham Walia by the dress yeah
exactly he causes a lot of city damage
Gillian Murphy was almost Bruce Wayne
they definitely have the screen test oh
my god you they I wanted to have a
screen test with him doing it I know he
was one of the top candidates for it I
love to him my favorite I call him
Jillian why does mean eh they're okay
it sounds like an old-timey like night
Jillian
well I feel like Killian mercury would
have been a creepy Batman I feel like it
would have been really different I just
think it would've still been interesting
I've never liked he's great in the movie
sunshine yeah and he's really great at
28 days later but I've never like loved
him in the sense of how I feel like I
can gravitate toward someone like
Christian Bale yeah yeah I mean Killian
Murphy is a guy I like because of the
strange kind of ah yeah I think he
doesn't in this in this way I almost
think it worked out for the best that he
played scarecrow because he was the only
villain who returned in all three movie
yeah and like each time he showed up
like it was a distinct moment and like
he brought equality to that character
where I'm like hey man like I'm glad
that you ended up there still there's
one character deserves a spin-off it's
character like from hard are from
caramel lenio have in the Nolan verse
should be scary yes yeah like a whole
life between yeah the first ones there
when he ends up is like the judge in the
weird a People's Court like like what
the hell was he doing to show in the
criminal underworld you never seem to be
put away from but kill something if
something seems like he kept escaping
Arkham yeah there's like eight or
something you know but yet he was still
kind of like plucking it for what long
like every time you show hopefully he is
the most cartoony part of those movies
in a good way and I'm really glad
knowing is not going to return to do the
Batman film I don't think he should ya
know nothing goes in I don't like people
are still asking for it some glass or
weird things people want Zack Snyder
direct and if you want no one directly
I'm like what what are these choices you
guys have look at that man that's tired
again
drag that magnet I don't want
Christopher Nolan return isn't because
like he's is the perfect three-peat like
even if the Dark Knight Rises
problematic like it's a distinct chunk
that is nice as it is and really need to
see him do anymore I think he did it
well guys I think honest trailers has
done it again
many junkies you guys Rock hopes to go
on again soon my movie vs. movie episode
the flick they should be out soon I
don't know why it's not out yet oh boy
they shot several episodes and only if
the runner out right now what it's kind
of upsetting the screen junkies my
favorite screen Joker's are JP actually
when I give on that whenever I see JC a
like a Collider event or a screen
junkies event I spend most of my time
agua JC you saw my favorite the love you
got we look like without that hat
probably totally different I was like
Michael Chiklis you probably just these
idea involving this is part of a scalp
smithing this is brain Saba now a brain
right all right guys you can subscribe
to the real rejects John is written for
Jerry on Twitter and Instagram is a
social media manager of blue house and
the real rejects and shout out to this
place I'm leaving all you're leaving
here I cannot wait to get the [ __ ] out
of here yeah there's cockroaches
cockroaches you kids who hang off the
balcony and none of them have died yet
from doing that and they were literally
manager here level box she's a [ __ ]
don't worry I'm gonna upload this video
after I moved here the big [ __ ] [ __ ]
big fan channel no one likes you in this
complex